bonjour antoine alors que retenir
justement de cette intervention de
sergueï lavrov à l'assemblée générale
des nations unies oui bien le ministre
russe des affaires étrangères a évoqué
de nombreux thèmes de politique
internationale et dressé un tableau
plutôt sombre des relations entre les
pays
il a regretté je cite la désunion
croissante de la communauté
internationale ce qui empêche d'après
lui de résoudre les problèmes endurés
coûté healy d'année en année de plus en
plus compliqué de réagir à ces problèmes
mondiaux et à bien d'autres surtout sur
fond de fragmentation croissante de la
communauté internationale
cette situation est en grande partie lié
comme nous le voyons au refus de
certains pays de tenir compte des
intérêts légitimes des autres pays
il recourt à l'implantation de concept
est standard à l'instar de l'ordre
international fondé sur des règles
en parallèle avec des tentatives
d'ingérence dans les affaires
intérieures des pays
l'application de sanctions unilatérales
en violation des prérogatives du conseil
de sécurité de l'onu et les
manifestations d'intolérance et de haine
afin d'y remédier il a appelé la
communauté internationale à mettre en
place une assistance mutuelle et une
coopération globale au lieu de diviser
les états entre ennemis et amis
de façon plus concrète le ministre russe
des affaires étrangères a entre autres
abordé le thème des grands traités du
contrôle des armements stratégiques et
implicitement regretter le retrait des
états unis de ces derniers regardent et
il convient de bloquer des efforts
visant à affaiblir le contrôle sur les
armements le désarmement et la non
prolifération afin de maintenir la
stabilité mondiale une attention
particulière devrait être accordée à la
lutte contre les menaces de nature
transfrontalière y compris celles
associées outrancière de combattants
terroristes étrangers vers des zones de
conflits aux menaces de terrorisme
chimique et biologique l'utilisation de
l'espace à des fins pacifiques doit
également être garantie enfin pour
prendre un peu de recul et se recentrer
sur la véritable mission des nations
unies qui l'a rappelé les préceptes des
pères fondateurs à savoir sauver les
générations futures du fléau de la
guerre asseoir la foi dans les droits de
l'homme
et créer les conditions d'un ordre
mondial juste et du progrès social
merci beaucoup antoine claireaux en
direct de moscou on vous retrouvera bien
sûr lors de nos prochaines éditions